okay hi my name is John Green and this
is my brother Hank actually do we have
any more like humiliating footage of
Hank perfect right so this is my brother
Hank off topic but dancing is funnier
when you remove the music
Hank is 29 he's a video blogger and a
musician and he also runs the
environmental technology website eco
geek Hank started eco geek when he was
in graduate school and it's grown and
grown and now it's like a business so
when people say that small business is
the engine that drives job growth in
America they're talking about Hank right
so the other thing you need to know
about Hank is that besides being a video
blogger and a songwriter and the CEO of
eco geek he is also a dude who has
alterative colitis which is the kind of
disease where you don't really want to
know the details but basically it's like
your whole body is on earth except for
your intestines which are in hell so
anyway in the United States if you work
for a big company that big company is
required to partner with a private
health insurance company and required to
offer you health insurance so the funny
thing about America is that if you're
really poor you can get health insurance
you can get on Medicaid and if you're
really old you can get health insurance
you can get on Medicare the people who
can't get health insurance are the
people who are not poor not old and
don't work for a big company and in fact
my brother Hank despite having a
successful business and despite being
the engine that drives job growth in
America could not get health insurance
for many years because health insurance
companies don't like to cover people
with ulcerative colitis because
ulcerative colitis in addition to being
crappy no pun intended
is also incredibly expensive this isn't
because health insurance companies are
evil or anything they just don't see
Hank as a good investment because he's
not a good investment
like Hank has to take this medicine that
cost 20 dollars a day every day and
there's a greater risk that he might get
colon cancer which is an incredibly
expensive disease so that sucks for Hank
but you know lots of things suck for
Hank and I don't want to be responsible
for fixing all of them like for instance
when Hank was a little kid he liked My
Little Ponies and I spent the last 25
years of his life humiliating him about
it but I don't want have to pay for the
therapy Hank needs to deal with the
shame and humiliation of his my little
pony fetish right I mean the government
is not in the business of giving people
everything they want or even actually
everything they need but government is
in the business of protecting us that's
why we have a military that's why our
government negotiates trade treaties
with other countries and that's why we
put off
regulations on the free market like for
instance not letting Walmart sell black
tar heroin to children and also like not
letting Toys R Us sell Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles slathered in wet paint so
here's what happened to Hank the state
of Montana which by the way is not known
for its liberal bias partnered with a
private insurer to create a somewhat
affordable plan that offers health
insurance to anyone who needs it
regardless of whether they have a
pre-existing condition so now Hank has
health insurance he doesn't have
prescription drug coverage so he still
has to spend twenty bucks a day on pills
but he doesn't have to worry so much
about getting colon cancer and going
bankrupt which has in turn allowed him
to invest more money in Eco geek and in
building his company so that it employs
more people this is the real
conservative economic argument for why
we need a public option for health
insurance all across America the system
as we have it encourages you either to
be poor to be old or to work for a big
corporation it discourages the
entrepreneurial spirit that made
America's economy strong in the first
place it says to young entrepreneurs
don't start your own business don't be
the engine that drives job growth in
America
go and work for a big corporation so you
can have health care it's just really
bad economics to have the job decisions
of your citizenship based not on revenue
growth but instead on health care costs
Hank you'll see me on Tuesday